[Music]
are you a virgin
body count matter
wait no no no no no we all have
everything that I don't need and not
providing anything that I do need what's
up with
hello hey what's up how are you I'm good
thank you how are you what's your name
what's your name Danielle MTO Donya
pleasure to meet you that's a very
pretty name thank you
thank you it's a pleasure to meet you
though you too you're from here
yeah I'm from London you're from London
proper
okay you've been here okay your entire
life I'm from New York
yeah I haven't been to New York properly
before so have you been to United States
I've been to Canada so you've been to
Canada
okay yeah that's not the United States
I can't see our eyes I'm sorry
these are prescription now I can't see
you
oh you like my eyes
you like my eyes I like your eyes too
yeah oh
she's cool
a lot of modern women I'm just I'm just
confused at what they think who I am you
know what I'm saying okay we gotta all
right all right anyway listen Dania with
your pretty name
okay so you from him what do you do for
a living I'm a dental nurse you're a
dental nurse like a hygienist that we
call them that in the states no
hygienist is different they clean the
teeth I just um I do the dirty work for
the dentist oh I suction the mouth and I
like to prepare the fillings and stuff
so I do all the stuff I take the x-rays
it's like a dental assistant yeah Dental
nurse dental assistant that's the one
that's what's up okay what do you do I'm
a YouTuber okay okay right now yeah I
used to I was in Corporate America
um I have a business degree I was doing
that for a while and it started a
YouTube channel at the same time that I
was doing that and a year and some
change ago I made the transition and now
I just create content online really when
someone asks me I just say I talk [__]
online that's that's assassin is really
just that's really just what I do enjoy
it yeah fully however it's way more
stressful than anything that I've ever
worked on before in my life so it's a
great deal of enjoyment but at the same
time it's extremely stressful yeah well
you shouldn't stress just gives you
wrinkles it does give me wrinkles you
think I'm doing good I'm 37 years old
yeah
how old are you I'm 20
. 22. that's a good age limit oh they
can't see me winking never mind I can't
see me it can't see me anyway what'd you
do yesterday last night I was on podcast
yesterday oh you were
was it
did we were you on my podcast
not your one I don't think okay just
making sure I'm like damn like you clean
up well man you clean you you clean up
well if you was on the one that I did
yesterday okay it was a different
podcast Maybe maybe okay awesome so
um let's get down to it actually a
certain set of questions because at 22
years old what I think though is that
you know you're probably are you crying
did you go to college
well I didn't go to college but I
haven't qualified Dental nurse and a
qualified PE therapist okay so what they
call that uni here
um so I guess you could say College
college I think it's University I don't
have a University degree got you so but
you you're certified within that okay
um okay so that's kind of the rail some
of the questions I was getting ready to
ask you but I always want to ask you
just some some topical stuff and feel
free to be able to ask me questions as
well but like oh here are red pill
Bachelor we like to get down to the
nitty-gritty we like to get down into
the gristle you understand what I'm
saying so like first and foremost
what do you think about the word
submission
I don't think it's a negative thing okay
um I think when you get into a
relationship you do naturally submit to
someone that you love I think you submit
to your family and you're you're very
very close Circle
so yeah okay so you submit to those
things within family in close Circle
probably work as well but what about
your man
okay
I would if I
fully Loved Someone and I trusted them
then I wouldn't see why I wouldn't trust
their judgment so be a virgin
no yeah
body count matter I know
um
that body count question is
because guys are like okay if you
weren't in a relationship what were you
doing
[Music]
yeah I knew it was coming
to an extent explain that extent I mean
for a man I wouldn't want someone I
don't know what I think it's more about
how someone carries themselves yeah
rather than like how many people they've
been with but I would say when a man has
been with a lot of women and he's the
kind of man that brags about it I find
it very unattractive okay so what if
he's been with a lot of women but he
doesn't brag about it
know what to say isn't it
it's kind of hard to say yeah I guess
ignorance is bliss ignorance is bliss so
you wouldn't ask him about it you
wouldn't care it wouldn't be a question
that I would ask
I understand
all right so submission you're okay with
the term body count I kind of got like a
I don't really understand what really
the answer is you know what I mean so
what about for women do you feel as
though for women body count matters do
you think it matters more from for women
or for men
um
statistically I think it matters more
for women I feel like men view women
differently
but at the same time
that I'll it just depends how you carry
yourself because if you sleep with a lot
of men and then you carry yourself a bit
loose and stuff then obviously men
aren't gonna
view the same okay in my opinion
okay
um judging from what you think men would
find typically normal
for
um amount of men slept with do you think
that you're above average or below
average but I below average okay
um do you have any hobbies I do okay um
I love to cook okay
she's not doing
muscles you know damn well Auntie
there's actually a World Championships
yeah pole dancing I've seen online yeah
yeah
it's actually hot okay I'm just saying
where I'm from they're not having their
ones they're not they're not having your
wife
actually a lot of them
right but are you leading with that on
the first date yeah we went from cooking
to pole dancing
honestly no he talking about that sound
like wifey to me
you're looking for exactly right because
I myself don't mind like I think it's
fun and interactive and I would love to
do that for my husband behind the scene
but am I leading with that on the first
date well and if this is
I just can't imagine I'm just thinking
where I'm from what's your wife doing
this afternoon she's going to a pole
dancing club like I just the guys I know
would not it's something we keep it to
myself Boo in the bedroom all your
friends don't need something I just wish
our class oh okay what what's the last
thing that you cook that's the first
thing uh slow cooked lamb with couscous
and I need some mint yogurt we're cool
schools is that a is that a is that a
United Kingdom thing you never had
couscous no I've only heard it what is
the couscous is that like a is that a
bean dip what is that it's like a gray I
guess like it's they have it in like
Greek cuisine and poker like Middle
Eastern
couscous you shallow cook that too you
just slow cook the lamb
interesting you made that for yourself I
did okay you ever cooked for a man
before uh-huh
uh-huh okay how was that was that an
enjoyable experience I do I love to cook
I cook our friends and my
mom you got guy friends I
uh how many girlfriends you got a lot
well not a lot but I have a circle
mostly in the garden okay like five sex
are they attractive they are they're
okay
okay have you kissed any of them
ever in your life no
no I'm gonna kiss on the
side no like kid like
your girlfriend's like no they're not
like on a look on the lips you kiss all
your girlfriends on your lips so I feel
like it's been like cosplay
no no no no no no
you kiss all your girlfriends on the
lips like your friends who are girls yes
my mouth's not been up no especially not
wait did she say she kisses her no she's
female friends she said it was a normal
thing some places yeah yeah
a kiss on the lips
maybe that's what she does is it popular
22 though here it's not culturally well
I was 22 at one point I don't know if it
was lips in my female you're currently
20 21 right yeah
cultural
unless you want in attention from the
office
is that common in Nigeria because her I
think her dad is Nigerian okay oh you're
Nigerian too okay
like English people that do that they
tend to kiss their sons and everybody on
their lips because you must have some
old white English people sometimes they
approach you and you just have to switch
your mouth
Auntie do you genuinely think that's
what it was
I think you know I think that she's I
think it's innocent yeah I don't think
it's like anything I do think
I think there'll have to be some
provocative things being dropped here to
insinuate some things that's just what
that's what I'm picking up it sounds
like it that's what I mean I honestly I
know people who do that yeah and it's
not ever an innocent thing it's like
attention there's something yeah like
either attention seeking trying to make
everyone look at them
or she might be especially like girls as
well as guys yeah
sexually liberated Italian Vibe you know
she said on the mouth yeah that's
different on the cheeks yeah
um
you know what I'm saying
you know I think there's nothing wrong
with a young lady that's like maybe you
know like maybe you know five to ten
percent buy you know what I mean I I
don't think anyone was completely
straight I'll be honest you really yeah
yeah okay
anyway in modern day as well do you
think you are you about five to ten
percent bye probably okay okay she
checked and appreciate it I appreciate a
good missing woman so a good set of
memory glands a good biscuit Center you
know I do as well we have something in
common so you said you pole dance let's
get into that let's get into that so
hobby pole dancing is this at a studio
um in my house I'm self-taught
self-taught so about three about three
years on and off but I've taken it more
seriously in the last year so Okay do
um so self-taught you YouTube it YouTube
um literally I just watched my whole
Instagram feed is just pole dancing and
so is my Tick Tock so I just watch
videos and I kind of try and recreate
the video and I guess that's kind of how
I look do you have any so there's not a
poll in here but do you have like
examples
you said you could spin around what spin
around the pole if it was in the ring if
it was in the room damn it where's the
pope listen y'all have everything that I
don't need and not providing anything
that I do need what's up with Munich
where's Pearl at big pearl back no I'm
just
do you have any examples that I could
put my phone on me you have your phone
on you you got an Instagram
hola wait a minute let's do the exchange
he's she's closing in he's already
asking for the
that too but it's like a Sly way so it's
the open communication yeah
what's the main using the DM for though
what do you mean what's she using the DM
for you using a DM to find love to find
some for the night
exactly but in the midst of me finding
something to do I can find a little
inside of that how is it that turned out
for you though have you ever found it we
still looking we still looking what's
your next song called
what's your next song called
exactly
yeah I personally don't think it's a
good way to start
um something like if if you want to look
for a relationship this isn't really the
way to do it Instagram and then pull
down no oh Paul dancing I think I think
this is a date to lead to like a
one-night stand yeah I think in modern
days right now what they should have
done is just look at each other's IG
first look at the profile and I would
say at this point in stage we were
already on the date I need you to be
asking for my number don't ask me for my
Ig at this point like what's my number
how do you want to continue to see me in
the future what's next foreign
okay let's put it in there I see you got
a um a piercing right in your rib cage I
did that means do you like pain
um
I'm not scared of needles if that's what
you mean
no no what I mean is do you like pain
that's me do I like pain I mean
um
I wouldn't say I love it but like
I don't know I don't really know how to
answer that question
if you got my reels I have a highlight
on my
oh you've okay so the podcast was here
I'm looking at this one right here yeah
yeah so the podcast was here can we okay
here goes one of them let's watch it
together let's can we put it on the
screen so the viewers can watch as well
are you strong
so you've been doing this for three
years oh
a year ago and I've I've pulled a lot
more now
do you teach classes yet because you you
seem good enough where you can teach
classes I don't teach classes but it's
definitely the goal maybe in the future
to maybe do competitions or something
sure if you do something here's the
thing my business might
I think I just saw the insides I I like
like my um my business mind fires in
such a way where I'm just like you
create a YouTube channel start talking
to Young lovely young modern women
who've been watching the city girls
their entire life and they want to
understand the ways that they can can
increase their sexual their their sexual
being their sexual essence you know you
uh you can do some consultations
you don't know that it's in America
never mind them
they're fools okay
um the so let's say that um I know this
is your hobby for about three years or
so but if we was today date
and I wanted you to not post
reels like that or tick tocks like that
how would that make you feel well I mean
if it was it was for a
like money saw perspective do you make
money off of this no not money from the
posts but I get job opportunities from
it so like people have asked me to be in
music videos or like again even come on
a podcast or yeah and talk about things
so yeah from that I think it opens a lot
of doors for me and it does put me in a
community with a lot of other pole
dancers that pole dance for like Fitness
and stuff which is got it so you
wouldn't you wouldn't remove this if I
was like I don't know if you didn't feel
comfortable with it then like we could
yeah something
but the poll would stay
the poll would say it's my hobby I have
a passion for it so yeah the same way
you have a passion for your YouTube yeah
do you have hobbies yeah but I make
money from the YouTube
you know I would like to make money from
Paul
you should start a YouTube channel
they're thinking about you've been
thinking about it you need some coaching
maybe maybe you can coach me my
consultation fees is extremely high
exactly
do you have any hobbies other than
YouTube
um yeah I got some Hobbies um I like the
Box
um I'm new though I'm not like good
quite yet
um not even an amateur because when I
hear amateur that means like amateur
boxing okay you know so that means like
in some of the amateur boxes be good as
[__] you know what I'm saying so like
not even on that level quite yet but
like um I like to work out I like to
stay physically fit I'm 37 and people
will be looking at me sometimes like how
are you even it's because like I love to
exert myself yeah so you know all of
that um anguish and pain or anxiety just
kind of you put it into something more
productive exactly yeah I you know I
think like you absorb [__] and you gotta
let it go you know if you don't it just
ages you your body your organs and turns
into different calamities within your
body right so you got to exert that's
what your body is made for we are energy
exchanges 100 ideas
so I think
um
um being involved with a an activity
that makes you sweat you know yours is
pole dancing mine right now is boxing
but mine has changed over time so that's
one of the things that I'm into as a kid
I loved fishing I also love you love
fishing yeah I'll get to the mountains
and how far away is a pond here
you can you cook the fish after I didn't
cook the fish it has a gut fish as well
oh she talented she multi
-cups oh you with the shits I love the
Wilderness I thought you go up in London
proper I grew up in London but I had a
time in the highlands in Scotland
camping a lot and stuff so my uncle
oh [__] so you all up into the survival
stuff
okay that's stuck in a forest together
I'd be able to tell you like which
mushrooms
get out of here
the man's were all doing all of these
things is this a masculine yeah she's
she's being the leader and being like
the man in the problem solver when
actually it's the man's job to do that
so I think that's not a great route to
go on a first date personally I think
it's up to the man to lead I can show
which mushrooms to eat too but the guys
there's a question for me
[Music]
I disagree
I think for men we just look for women
that would listen to us when we want to
speak so you can say whatever you want
to say you can be able to do whatever
you want to do but whenever we have a
decision to make you have to be able to
listen it's as simple as that when it
comes to like life and death yeah that's
what I'm saying so when it comes to
serious issues we don't want no argument
but in general life you can be the
leader if you want what she's doing now
she's not coming up with I can knit and
I can sew she's coming to masculine
things she's trying to say well you know
what I can do this because those are
things that men like doing yeah so it's
like yeah you want to go fishing I can
fish whereas women be like I don't want
to go fish exactly sitting there for
hours
the fish it's raw she's like I can do
that I can do this I mean so she's
trying to make herself more attractive
to him but she just said she can shoot a
gun I can shoot yeah men love that yeah
men love that I love it men love that I
I feel like it's more of a manly thing
to do than it is but it doesn't mean
that you can't be feminine and it's sexy
for about everything every man take he
likes fishing I mean she's gonna go I'm
just thinking like
um okay let's take this would you rather
have a girl that shoots a gun or does
ballet like wouldn't you rather have a
girl that does ballet or do you not care
shoot the gun if I was a man shoot the
gun no I'm asking the guys
I'm just wondering I want a girl that we
can do things together okay I'm not
going to do ballet why not right now I
think I would like to watch that
okay cool you want to tell me the
mushrooms is gonna make me um be
introspective about life yeah you can
tell me those too maybe
[Laughter]
yo that's definitely what's up listen I
wanna I wanna ask you a quick question
because I just noticed something about
you and so put can you put out your own
I just noticed come on here
what's this
oh I had an accident when I was younger
I'll say wow
okay you don't want to talk about that
that's fine that's fine yeah that's fine
I just yeah I saw her and I'm like I
just wanted to yeah okay pass that now
so past it yeah it's um it's a time in
your life that you grew Beyond
that's definitely what's up I think that
you know we're all imperfect beings and
we're trying to get somewhere else
within life at the end of the day so 100
sometimes it's not about you know what
happened to us previously is so much as
we what we can make ourselves into the
future it's character building
absolutely character building yeah every
every strong character needs to have a
damn a bad start you know some [__] that
they wish that they can fix at the end
of it oh the red light just came on that
means we got to ask the crazy questions
asked me a question okay so so what is
your ideal woman I do
ideal woman is a woman that number one
understands the difficulties of being a
man that understands
how to please a man
and the thing is is that when I say
something like that I don't think it's
very hard to please a man especially me
like I'm a very E I would say I'm a very
easy guy
to please right feed me
inspire me give me peace and drain my
balls
that's really it at the end of the day
like those things right there but the
piece is probably number one I'll be
honest with you right like after peace
is probably is probably number one but
at the end of the day like those are
just the four components and and like
but I feel like there's in modern day
culture and society today there is a um
how do you say like
um the things that men prioritize is not
value
right men's experiences is not valued so
if so if I can find a woman that sees it
understands the value of it and lets
boys be boys or lets men be men
that has a rare one right there but I
feel like most modern women today are
not conditioned to think that way the
condition to think about what's in it
for me
or what he can do for me
yeah does that make sense
it doesn't make sense all right this is
the hot round though you got access
oh
[Music]
time is up
Dania
wow it's a pleasure to make your
acquaintance die yeah me too all right
am I going okay
okay look at more I'm gonna look at more
of your videos down here oh I even see
the whole oh
come on
how tall are you I'm five foot two five
foot two yeah I'm tiny
yeah you are
yo I really want to know what you guys
think about Diane in the comment box
down below there's a lot of things that
I picked up within that conversation
um that I was you know
um befuddled by that's a good word right
word my London belongs don't take the
SAT we do that over in America all right
um here's the thing I'm gonna bring her
back probably most likely for another
round because there's so many other
questions that I really would like to
ask her I went to her first couple of
photos within her Instagram I started
going down deeper in it and I'm saying a
lot
a lot within this I'm gonna dive deeper
on the Instagram kind of going up into
it she gives me fun girl vibes
she gives me
um if I want to experience something new
she'd be down for it ready willing and
able oh my God is this a photo where I
can see her vagina yep on her Instagram
how do they even allow this [__] they
would have canceled your boy for just
talking about my women today well we got
women up here showing their clitoris and
they're loud as [__] the nerve hey man
can I get a hug if a man's not gonna see
you in public and say you're his
girlfriend
it's a situationship I don't think that
that title was is necessary unless you
think about the next step and you need
to take it at face value when he say it
don't think oh
thank you